2 millions d'euros c'est le montant
record l'an dernier en Indre-et-Loire
des dégâts de gibier sur les récoltes
factures que vont payer les chasseurs
pourtant les dégâts ne sont pas plus
importants alors comment expliquer ce
paradoxe notre invité nous en dit plus
ce soir on sort Alain bonsoir vous êtes
président de la fédération de chasse
d'Indre-et-Loire
13500 chasseurs dans le département
d'abord rappelez-nous pourquoi ce sont
les chasseurs qui paient des dégâts de
gibier sur les cultures c'est une loi de
1968 où il a été mis sur papier que les
agriculteurs n'avaient plus le droit
d'affût pour défendre leur culture mais
qu'en contrepartie c'était chasseur qui
prenaient en charge les goji billets à
l'époque les il y avait 30 000 chasseurs
dans le département d'indre-et-loir et
très très peu d'animaux alors qui
déclare ces dégâts c'est les
agriculteurs conjointement avec les
chasseurs comment ça se passe
agricole a des dégâts sur une parcelle
il ouvre un dossier auprès de la
fédération départementale qui dans les 8
jours est chargé de le faire estimer
et c'est un constat qui est fait qu'on
sera amiable qui est fait entre
l'agriculteur et l'estimateur et
derrière s'enclenchent un dossier donc
un nombre une surface un nombre de
quintaux détruit multiplié par un prix
de référence alors on va voir cette
facture des dégâts 2 millions d'euros
pourtant il n'y a pas eu plus de culture
détruite c'est ce que vous nous avez dit
comment on explique cet écart ce
paradoxe simplement par la fluctuation
du marché des céréales qui a énormément
bougé ou le enfin on l'entend dans dans
la vie tous les jours notamment à la
gare en Ukraine un premier clash donc
les chasseurs c'est la deuxième grand
clash avec la guerre en Ukraine qui
arrive l'année dernière et qui multiplie
presque par deux le prix des céréales
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont à combien
aujourd'hui
un blé comme indemniser en 170 euros
tonnes il y a deux ans on l'a indemnisé
cette année 320 euroston 1000 hectares
de terrain détruit cette année sur 350
000 hectares de culture d'Indre-et-Loire
350 plus tard quels sont les animaux qui
sont responsables de ces destructions
c'est les sangliers c'est les billets à
moitié moitié 50% pour les sangliers 50%
briser un tout petit pourcentage pour
les chevreuils dans les vignes qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire vous allez devoir payer
plus cher pour pourchasser pour éponger
cette facture complètement c'est un
dossier très lourd pour la fédération
départementale mais très lourd pour
chaque chasseur qui chasse en
Indre-et-Loire puisque ce sont les
chasseurs seuls qui payent les dégâts de
gibiers et c'est réparti cette somme est
répartie sur l'ensemble des chasseurs et
des territoires alors ça se retrouve sur
le permis de chasser ou sur d'autres
frais donc des vous acquittés trois
formules de financement le permis de
chasser il y a une somme qui est prise
pour aller dans la navigation des
gueules l'animal on ne prélève que des
animaux qui sont attribués passés par
une commission d'attribution quarantaine
d'euros c'est ça pour un 40 euros pour
un sanglier 160 euros pour un service et
de participation territoriale c'est
quand ça ne suffit pas et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui une participation
territoriale qui était spa connaissait
répartir au plus juste sur les
territoires et c'est très très compliqué
c'est à dire que quand les chasseurs
chassent ils louent une parcelle et sur
cette parcelle et prélever une taxe et
c'est là en plus de cette
occasion est prélevé une participation
territoriale pour indemniser dégageries
alors pas plus de dégâts pourtant la
préfecture elle estime qu'il y a
toujours trop de sangliers là donc
décidé d'interdire la drainage en
janvier février c'est à dire le fait de
nourrir artificiellement les animaux ce
que c'est une bonne chose que vous
pensez que ça va réduire la population
de sangliers non c'est une fausse une
fausse bonne idée
on l'a testé la préfecture
l'administration l'a fait tester depuis
4 ans
on peut partir du principe que si on
aurait pu si on agrène plus on n'est pas
dans le nourrissage on est dans de
l'agrenage
on pouvait penser que ça
l'a grégnage ce n'est pas de la c'est
pas de l'alimentation de tous les jours
c'est quelques grains quand on compare
la grainage à une frictions
c'est du nourrissage le nourrissage nous
combattons nous le combattons fédération
départemental nous les combattants nous
le combattons avec un manque de moyens
puisque l'administration devrait nous
aider sur ce dossier là on n'avait pas
le faire et et aujourd'hui arrêter la
ganache c'est une dispersion des animaux
qui ne seront pas prélevés parce que
dans la plaine il n'y a pas les
structures de chasse pour les prélever
et demain matin ils vont rester sur
place et ils vont nous faire des dégâts
sur les parcelles merci beaucoup Alain
Benois président de la fédération de
chasse d'un valoir est venu ce soir sur
notre plateau